foreign
I think my biggest learning from taking
an unconventional path was probably
continuing to be intrinsically motivated
by this sort of curiosity so I think a
lot of young people should figure out
what gets themselves ticking and drives
them
I started a company called alloy we are
a business process automation tool so
what that means is we allow you as a
business user to connect the different
apps you use and essentially automate
work across those apps so what that
means for a brand like Brooklyn for
example is you can connect to your
loyalty platform to your subscriptions
platform so if I subscribe to
pillowcases me as a customer I can
automatically get rewards when I hit say
the 12th subscription renewal so we
actually allow Brands and The Operators
behind them to automate that sort of
work
this is my first company the Catalyst
for starting it is kind of out of just
my personal philosophy on life so I love
saving time I love to optimize
everything in my life so I basically
wanted to make it easy for anyone to do
that themselves without having to code
so when I was younger I actually built a
lot of apps for myself in my daily life
and I realized it's probably not
practical for everyone to do that
[Music]
I left High School a bit early to go
work in Silicon Valley and so I had a
really interesting experience there for
six or eight months I actually went
without really telling my parents and
they we didn't really talk for a bit and
then I applied to Harvard and got in
kind of in an unconventional way so they
asked me for my portfolio of code I
didn't really have a great resume as a
high schooler so I got him purely
because of my extracurricular things and
so when I went to Harvard it was
actually very different from my
experience in Silicon Valley so I felt
like there's a lot of hierarchy it
actually moved a lot slower than I would
have liked so I left after my first year
to work in the valley again and I didn't
expect to fully drop out but I kind of
just never went back so if you could
call it an infinite leave of absence
I started the company when I was 18 and
obviously a lot of VCS a lot of people
we partner with at Legacy companies they
haven't really seen a very young Asian
girl walk into the room unless they're
like an associate or an assistant so it
does surprise people and when I was
starting my career or starting my
company I wore ripped jeans and a hoodie
so it was also very different but I
think it caught people so off guard that
they weren't that like close-minded
I'm grateful that I work in Tech where
people actually respect you if you know
how to code and so I came in with that
sort of background and a lot of times
you actually interface with people over
like forums first and so you don't see
each other's faces so a lot of times
when I was doing business I actually
built up Rapport over email and only
when I kind of showed up in person
people would be surprised
today at alloy were 30 people and we
have a couple thousand Brands using us
and actually we've been able to scale a
lot from great word of mouth on social
platforms like Twitter actually the
fundraising Journey was actually really
tough for us when we started since I did
why I see the accelerator with my
co-founder when it was still in person
and then the pandemic hit in March of
2020 so YC typically has a demo day at
the very end of the batch and that
actually didn't really happen so we
didn't have demo day to help us
fundraise and so I basically had to
learn how to do it while everyone
thought the world was ending so it was
super tough to put together 1 million at
the start of our journey and then over
time things actually got much easier as
we got more traction as the markets got
a bit better so in total we've actually
raised 27 million our most recent round
was 20 million from Andreessen Horowitz
so that was a series A
[Music]
I want my legacy to be of someone who
built beautiful products that made
people enjoy their lives more and in
general I want to be remembered as
pretty curious intellectual individual
[Music]
[Music]